c'est d'abord une rencontre épistolaire
la lettre d'une inconnue en 1832 sera la
première d'une correspondance de 18 ans
entre honoré de balzac et madame en ce
cas les premières réponses de balzac
commence par madame en 1833 c'est mon
cher et pur amour qui débutent les
missives balzac est un grand romantique
savez durant je ne peuvent pas l'ignorer
et donc elle était dans les crèmes pour
rejoindre l'être aimé la belle
étrangères madame en ce cas ça a
commencé en 1833 son apothéose en 1834
et finalement c'est en 49 qu'il est allé
en ukrainien plat pour la première fois
la fait deux voyages en ukraine c'est
sergueï karaganov qui a photographié les
voyages réels ou possible au palais de
madawaska vert qu'il ya un vertige chef
et kiev des lieux de l'ancienne province
polonaise et d'ukraine sa photographe
l'ukrainien que nous a transmis ses
clichés mais aussi à essayer avec des
historiens de recréer le voyage
hypothétique de ces deux amants plus
calmes ans puisque se sont mariés à
l'occasion du deuxième voyage en 1850
quelques mois avant le retour en france
elle 17 balzac balzac en ukraine c'est
la première exposition qui débutent les
festivités du 220e anniversaire de la
naissance de l'écrivain
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 14
avril au château de tours